extraordinary accomplishments come from
doing ordinary things for Extraordinary
periods of time but when I was younger
my action showed that I was more
impatient I thought there was some
Shortcut I didn't know about I would see
the guys on stages being like this is
what we do we do the basics and we do a
lot of it I was like they're just trying
to hold the secrets back and I'm here to
tell you that that is not true working
out and doing reps is not extraordinary
if you saw one set of a workout for me
at the gym you wouldn't think oh this
guy is amazing it's the fact that you do
it for 23 years nothing about that is
extraordinary it's the dedication to
doing it over and over and over and over
again despite feeling like there's
better opportunities despite people
approaching you with new and exciting
things but saying that you're committed
to the original Vision you had and that
not the action itself but your
commitment to the action is what makes
someone extraordinary not the thing
itself and to me that made being
extraordinary possible